[Musique]
elle est activement pour l'instant voilà
je kiffe ses sodas fait il ya que lui
qui peut mettre en place un moment
détente au barça
ça va le col ou pas la malbouffe ou pas
alors là tout me va
mais non couderc bout des doigts la
bouder tâche en plus bonjour aux gens
toi tu passes devant moi je dis pas
bonjour
t'inquiète ce paraphe jusqu'à je te vois
dans le jazz et je sais que c'est toi je
t'ai vu je t'ai vu c'est pas nous
tranquilles car alors t'es pas d'accord
c'est pas une photo regarde c'est bien
toi oh là là whaou à mal
désiré tagro n'ya jamais compris on est
d'accord
[Musique]
sa part à terre et à l'eau les parties
françois mais je vous attends vie
d'aurélie en guest ma petite kelly que
j'aime beaucoup
on est très copines on s'entend très
bien donc voilà dans l'épisode il ya
kelly voilà
[Musique]
voilà le débit bravo
risa ça va tu es prête pour le voyage
j'étais prêt
[Musique]
les amériques j'avais mes chances mais
l'allusion à les jeter
[Musique]
j'espère que le son soit vous a plu et
puis on se dit à très vite pour la suite
des aventures en laponie
[Musique]